Lucy leppy was supposed to be protecting
and nursing the children in her care
instead she was killing them in a manner
described as cold cruel and relentless
her violence took different forms some
babies had air injected into their
bloodstream others were poisoned with
insulin the criminal trial lasted 10
months the verdict guilty I've been
asked to read out a statement on behalf
of all the families in this case
words cannot effectively explain how we
are feeling at this moment in time we
are quite simply stunned today justice
has been served and a nurse who should
have been caring for our babies has been
found guilty of harming them
what this Justice will not take away
from the extreme hurt anger and distress
and we've all had to experience
at the Intensive Care Unit for newborn
babies letby took advantage of their
vulnerabilities to disguise the harm she
was inflicting on them in 2015 and 2016
there was a significant increase in the
number of babies suffering sudden
unexplained collapses each time the only
nurse on duty was Lucy letby
it wasn't until June 2018 that letby was
first arrested at her home there
detectives found a notebook revealing
her emotional turmoil I haven't done
anything wrong she'd written but further
down the same sheet she'd added I am
evil I did this
the jury agreed
I cannot begin to imagine
how the families in this case feel today
I just hope that the today's verdicts
bring all of them some peace of mind for
the future
and that we have answered some of the
questions that they were looking for
the case has also raised important
questions about the hospital and its
procedures an external review discovered
significant gaps in nursing rotors and
insufficient Staffing at the high
dependency unit and concerns raised
about lepi in 2015 seemed to have been
ignored by Hospital management she went
on to kill two more babies
the hospital is now Under New Management
since Lucy letby was removed from Duty
there's been only one death there in the
past seven years
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera